I got an iPad for a gift
and I didn't know how to set it up so I
gave it to him
and I go man will you set this up for me
I don't know how to do it he was joking
and he brings it back later and he goes
here you go Dad all stood up first of
all I don't talk like this or laugh like
oh at least I don't scream when I laugh
like my dad when he goes ah just so you
know your iPad is the cloud everything
from everybody's devices goes to your
iPad everybody hearing that
everything from everybody's devices my
iPad
probably should have gone to my phone to
turn off the iCloud sharing everything
on my phone ends up on his iPad you know
as a man when you're
sitting on your own bed looking at your
own iPad looking at your pictures you
never want this sentence to leave your
mouth
well that's not my dick
I give him that one you never want to go
through your phone or your iPad or any
of your stuff and see somebody else's
dick a big red flag at first I thought
somebody was sending my wife dick pics
and I had that one beat that's a lie